now let's bring in har meat dylan
harmeet what would you do if you're
president trump would you support the
release of this affidavit
well first i do represent the president
in various civil matters but i'm not
speaking as a part of his criminal
defense team and so i think it is
important for the lawyers who are
looking at that affidavit to look at it
and then make their consider judgment as
to whether it tells the true story in my
opinion i have said publicly the warrant
itself is really not the where the meat
is where the meat is is the affidavits
that underlie the warrant that is what
the fbi told the magistrate judge in
order to get this warrant and there may
have been more than one affidavit and so
it is unclear to me that the doj is
offering to unseal those they don't
usually unseal those until there's an
indictment and i think if the warrant
tells an incomplete story it may not be
to the advantage of the trump team to
unseal it at this time the whole story
needs to be told and i think that the
doj as you said in your intro brian is
really stumbling they're playing defense
they're trying to do this the opposite
way that it should be in the southern
district of florida the normal procedure
as i understand from criminal defense
attorneys who practice there is that
this conversation is supposed to be had
between the prosecution and the target
of the subpoena in advance and then you
go to the judge and and ask the judge
after that discussion is had here they
flipped that order they just went into
court without having that conversation
first and the judge has ordered them to
have that conversation so without seeing
it i can't really say but i do know that
it seems like they're not telling the
full story here what brought us to this
moment and i just to qualify it newsweek
has the story that merrick garland
didn't sign off on this they did it
without him his knowledge or without his
blessing didn't know exactly what was
going to happen next thing you know we
hear about a press conference and
harmeet they're late they're late to
give what a seven minute address without
taking questions what's the delay i
could you could have
you or i could have lived this in our
sleep what was what is going on behind
the scenes
it looked like a hostage video to me
brian it was really bizarre and and
frankly even earlier today you saw all
of the uh you know allies of the
administration sheldon whitehouse come
out and say oh of course this kind of
thing would have been well below the
scope of merrick garland that's
obviously nonsense when you're raiding a
former president's home which is
unprecedented it had to come from the
top it did come from the top and i think
that the doj is in damage control mode
here because if it really when i first
saw this news i said this has to be
about something else it can't be about
presidential records because it is
frankly ludicrous to go to this type of
you know
extreme tactics over some 18 month old
stale documents that who who cares this
this this librarian head librarian of
the national archives is up in arms he's
upset that his documents aren't there
where is his upset about obama's 30
million pages of documents where is his
upset about how hillary clinton treated
uh classified documents and on her
server this is a ridiculous premise for
a fbi swat team of 30 fbi agents to go
through for nine hours it just doesn't
add up and so i still think that's
what's happening here is that this raid
was a pretext for a fishing expedition
that has come up empty and now they're
trying to craft a different narrative to
explain their outrageous behavior and
their undermining of trust of the
american people i don't think anyone has
to tell any viewer that president trump
has been playing a perfect game but i
really challenge anyone who says he
hasn't had a really good week on monday
this egregious activity barring this
doesn't go a different direction which i
don't think it is especially after
speaking to so many people on his team
and hearing them worried about things in
the past but not this then you think
about the southern district of new york
and their what three year investigation
to produce nothing and then they meet
with the ag and his company's going
exceedingly well this might be one of
the best weeks for donald trump who
suddenly
has not only did he do perfect on the
primary this week but now he seems to
have most of the party lining up behind
him your final thought
well look it might be a good thing
politically but i think it's a bad thing
for the country to see the american
department of justice and fbi
act in this outrageous manner every
american should be afraid that they can
do this to you as well and that is not a
good place for this country to be they
need to stop
true uh and i get worried that the irs
is muscling up and they're gonna have
the same tactics army thanks so much
appreciate it subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight